hello folks welcome to rational science
and I hope you're all doing fine today
anyways today we have a great day we're
going to be going kind of swiftly here
fella comes uh the other day and asked
the following he says uh why are you
wearing jackets indoors
this jacket I guess uh this coat
uh well um I guess the first answer to
that is because it's cold
it's cold in here and you might say well
does this have anything to do with uh
Putin uh shutting down the gas to
Germany
uh no not really but it'd be nice to get
used to what's coming you know I mean I
think uh we all have to think about that
the fact that
um the energy whatever energy is will be
sniffed off and uh they're gonna have to
look for new sources but no that's not
the reason the reason is that I do not
use heating I haven't used it for many
years
uh I think the heating dries up the air
inside the home and so you know I I try
to stay away from that you would have to
put a humidifier to make up for that you
know
um I think it's better just to tough it
out that's the way I look at it so yeah
I don't use heating and uh no it's got
nothing to do with money it's got to do
with again with uh not not being healthy
I think that's what it's about so I had
uh the radiators in my house taken out
okay uh we had uh a lady
uh uh girl
woman I I don't know uh I I don't want
to offend her by calling those her
as any of those you know because today
you don't know maybe you got to call her
day or them or who knows what anyways uh
this Gulliver
uh she was arrested in in Russia
and this became a little bit of a
problem because they wanted to exchange
prisoners right uh file that they had in
the United States for many years a
Russian and they wanted to trade it for
her the problem is that there was
another fellow waiting in line for a lot
longer time than she was I think
Wheeling was his name nobody was going
to remember him anyways
um and somehow they decided to exchange
her and not him
and that makes you kind of Wonder you
know I mean you know uh
was that the right choice you know some
people are questioning that right and uh
you can see she's a pretty tall girl
because he's a basketball player and I
think the United States was expecting uh
her
um to you know bring the uh Russian
Fleet with her like Gulliver you know
pulling on the little plugins uh I guess
that never happened uh but I think what
is going to be happening is that she's
probably gonna be on the news uh
interviewed by you know all sorts of
people uh and that's one of the reasons
I think that she was released in other
words why the United States shows her
not the other fellow and it's again it's
because uh you know she's a bigger prize
political prize right
um you know I mean she's just a
basketball player the other guy
allegedly you know was a spy and even if
he wasn't he was there for a longer
period of time so you would think he's a
high I pray a higher priority from a
humanitarian point of view and instead
they chose politics and all these people
on all sides they do politics that's all
they do they're you know these are um
these are moves to try to get people to
you know
Underside in the elections that's
essentially it anyways uh here you can
see a little note that was out there
Brittany Greiner returned to the United
States Friday nearly 10 months after the
basketball star detention in Russia main
era what the most high profile American
jailed abroad
yeah she was a little higher profiled
than the other fellow that was and a
couple more that are over there for for
longer than her and says grinder status
as an openly wet gay black woman
uh-huh maybe that's got something to do
with uh why they released her right uh
her prominence in women's basketball and
her imprisonment in a country where our
30s have been hostile to the lgbtq
community heightened concerns for her
and I think that's what it's all about
right brought a tremendous attention to
the case yeah that's I think that's what
it's all about politics it's got nothing
to do with uh
you know with the possibility that
um you know that uh they would release
someone for humanitarian reasons it's
all politics
anyways
um I did a little research on uh topic
related to Extinction right and here's
uh one of the things that I found over
the past and in fact this it came out in
the news over the past 50 years male
labor force you know people like me
participation the share of men working
or actively and looking for work has
steadily Fallen as female participation
has climbed some Scholars have a grim
explanation for the trend okay and
there's one thought and he says the
conservative leading author of argues
that there has been a well a swell in
men who are what inert written off or
discounted by society and perhaps all
too often even by themselves
okay so men are getting out of work
women are going in
uh that's one Trend okay and there you
have the rest of it you can read it
later on but uh that's one Trend and
here um
you see the the uh chart okay uh as a
percentage of uh population you can see
that uh men uh for now
several years you would say decades have
been steadily going down as a percentage
of the labor force okay
so uh that's one issue that you got to
think about there is a major change not
only in the world affairs where um the
United States is compelling essentially
Europe to seize its uh dealings with
both Russia and China and so that's
happening and then within that we have
that the men are losing jobs to women
and I think maybe just maybe it's just
one thing you might want to consider the
fact that
um you know in the old days work was you
know going to war and plowing the fields
and they needed more muscle and maybe
that's why men went out there and did a
lot of that work today we do a lot of
computer work and that can be done just
as well by women and if they uh you know
get uh lower salaries which they
complain about that would explain why
more women also are entering the
workforce
okay another Trend that you might want
to keep in mind and here it is study
finds sperm count decreasing worldwide
okay scientists cannot explain why both
the quality and quantity of sperm have
been dropping since the 1940s
indications our pollutants may be
responsible this came out in 1992 and
um uh it said collated sperm count
reports Etc fifteen thousand men those
are the numbers that they I guess uh
looked at and found declining declining
sperm counts in the USA Western Europe
and the third world countries and you
can see all the numbers there they went
down essentially that's what they're
saying and says that's a problem because
uh men's reproductive organs adversely
affected by pollutants that's what they
thought it was pcbs and DDT known to
imitate some functions of the estrogen
hormone okay anyways the issues that the
the sperm count has been going down this
is more or less uh
known by lots of people out there it's
in the public domain uh other factors
they talk about nutrition stress and
socioeconomic status Etc right but it
does uh tend to affect fertility okay
and here let me show you the uh chart
okay this is what what it looks like
more or less for that report 1930 to
1990 okay it's more or less
shows that yeah it's been going down and
then there was another more recent
report and it shows this shows that
um even since the 1970s to today it's
been going down even further
so uh it's a confirmed Trend you could
say sperm count is going down uh will
that affect
um fertility yeah of course and I say
that we are the last humans on Earth and
that is part of the trend it all points
to the same thing that we're at the end
of the line and I think it's got nothing
to do or very little to do if anything
with pollutants and uh food and anything
of that nature it's got to do with
genetics it's got to do in my opinion
and it's got to do with the fact that
we've been inbreeding for over 200 000
years since the start of our species
okay
um talking about Extinction here we have
another piece of information this is Mr
stoltenberg uh he's uh head of the NATO
and he says uh they interviewed him the
other day he says if things go wrong
they can go horribly wrong it is a war
talking about Ukraine that can become a
full-fledged war that spreads into a
major war between NATO and Russia
and the question is whether it would
stop there or whether it would continue
into you know pressing the red buttons
okay
uh Kremlin has repeatedly accused NATO
allies of effectively becoming a party
to the conflict by providing Ukraine
with weapons right training Etc
and suggested that Vladimir Putin
suggested Moscow might think about using
what he described as the U.S concept of
what a preemptive strike
okay
uh maybe it's a saber rattling maybe
it's just uh you know
uh
giving ideas to the west to consider
that's what it's called the opposite
side you know think about it we might
give you a preemptive strike won't even
let you you know uh
know what hit you and that would
obviously lead to a an escalation of the
war and from there the question is
whether we would end up something like
this okay here it is okay
World War III how's that
okay
now that's uh those are great images you
think that's ever going to happen
one man alone that's that's all there is
out there finally
okay
will this ever happen will we have a
World War where uh everybody against
everybody and just you know killing each
other and destroying whatever's left on
the planet
okay so I don't know it's uh something
to think about
uh yes it might happen
um
the question whether
um we have the uh the where wiggle to
stop something like that from happening
uh right now you could say maybe it's
just politics but maybe the powers that
be are playing with fire
okay here's uh
something uh note that someone sent me
it goes like this says how long do
civilizations usually last says the
average age of Empires according to a
specialist on the subject the late Sir
John Globe is 250 years after that
Empires always die often slowly but
overwhelmingly from overreaching in the
search for Power
okay and then it says how old is the
United States well it's 245 years okay
and so the question is you know
um is this a good analogy or is this a
good study can we use
um what happened in history as a
blueprint for
what's happening now we can we can
expect to happen now and my answer is no
I'm saying we're leaving living in a
special age
and that age it will not be a repeat of
the past it's not like the United States
will be taking Empire right we'll be
taken over by a Chinese Empire or a
Russian Empire that will never happen
let me say it again that will never
happen it's impossible and I'll tell you
why because United States will never
never allow China to overtake it
military maybe economically that's one
issue but not militarily as soon as that
happens there will be a war an incident
will be created and there will be
confrontation okay the United States
will not allow China to even the score
with them okay because uh the United
States I think will realize or the
politicians in the United States will
realize what that entails okay
so yeah and we've learned our lesson
from the past and we won't let history
repeat itself that's my point
okay here's uh people who say bill money
will never disappear because the theory
is that uh money will have no value at
some point it keeps devaluating
evaluating devaluating that's one Trend
the other one is that you know the
workers will barely be able to reach the
end of the month if it continues like
that and more and more people will be
laid out of work out of real work you
know and again uh internet is not real
work uh it's entertainment and ads
commercials does not work okay but uh we
think it's work because creating what do
you call it value
okay
but anyways
um here's a here's the uh example that
money can go down to zero okay here it
is here we have by the end of 1863 we're
talking about the Civil War in the
United States the amount of currency in
circulation and we're talking about The
South was three times more than needed
by the economy leading to inflation and
sometimes what refusal to accept the
notes
so yeah it's possible that money goes
down to a point where people will not
accept the notes will not accept any
kind of money you say hey I'll give you
crypto and I don't want it it's got no
value it's just a number in a computer
okay I'll give you dollars or Euros uh I
don't want it because it has no value
it's just paper
and I'll give you gold that's just a
rock
and so on and so forth until you give
them something that has intrinsic value
someone will decide not to accept it at
some point if we continue to devalue the
money out there and uh the value
especially the uh work uh the the labor
you know the people put into the economy
it's labor that's going to go down to
zero uh in other words you're going to
get salaries that'll bury barely take
you to the end of the month
and that creates secondary problems such
as that you don't have enough disposable
income to buy you know more permanent or
long-term items such as cars and houses
and so that market will fall and it'll
be a trickle I don't think we can get
away from that I think we're headed in
that direction okay
and uh Paul says hey you know uh we're
not going to be so so low as to commit
cannibalism kind of thing you know when
when the whole world collapses we're
probably going to help each other and
kiss our neighbors
um
I don't think so so he says the
following he says do you really think
the law of the jungle survival of the
fittest applies to species of higher
stages
uh I don't know maybe he's talking about
higher stages like chickens that in a
coupe some are higher than others
do you really think nature wants war and
competition those higher Realms of
existence are you aware that physically
physics is dictated by metaphysical laws
that are beyond the tangible oh I didn't
know that uh that's news I thought it
was the other way around I thought that
um
it's not dictated by metaphysical laws
and yeah the some things are Beyond
tangibility like the rope and you know a
lot of uh phenomena out there such as
magnetism and gravity that's true but
not that it's dictated by metaphysical
laws I'm sure you understand that
there's a lot more than the eye can see
absolutely yeah there's uh there are
ropes out there you know that connect
every atom we can't see those and we
can't see the magnetic fields we can't
see gravity at the mediator of gravity
so yes I agree there and there are
universal laws above those phenomena but
in science we don't have laws okay
people who talk about laws are religious
people okay which can be observed in our
Dimension uh I can eat you if I can kill
you okay I'm not sure what he's
referring to there as far as observed in
our Dimension I have no idea what that
means if the lion has got no sense of
ethics does that mean us humans don't
need ethics either we can be
self-conscious if we're not we are this
at the same level of existence we are
animals but we shouldn't be
well these are people who think that
they are people you know that people are
not animals okay so uh I'm just gonna
have to educate this poor fellow because
uh and I hate to break it to them you
know but yeah we are animals and here he
is the categorization of us humans
humans the most abundant and widespread
species of
primates right characterized by by
pedalism etc etc what's a primate uh
diverse order of mammals
what's a mammal a group of vertebrate
animals
sorry to tell you but yes we are animals
we belong to the Animal Kingdom and uh
some people have you know
uh think that because we have a brain
that we have ability to think Beyond uh
the other animals in the Kingdom Animal
Kingdom uh we are not animals because of
that that we are different that we are
some somehow God put us as not as an
animal in Eden but as the gardener where
the guys who have to keep the garden uh
running you know we plant potatoes trees
whatever and we take care of the zoo
that uh God created uh no we are one of
the animals okay uh the fact that we
have a higher intelligence where the
king you can say of intelligence well
that's like saying that the cheetah is
not an animal because it's the king of
speed or the elephant is not an animal
because he's the king of bigness of
enormity you know uh someone's got to be
the winner in every category someone's
got to get a gold medal at the Olympic
at the these Olympics right and uh in
our case we won the gold medal in
intelligence in brain ratio whatever you
want to call it okay so we got a gold
medal and does that make us not a
competitor okay we're not animals
because of that
so yeah it's uh religious people who
believe that humans are not animals or
part of the animal kingdom we have more
similarities with animals than we have
differences in fact we have no
differences whatsoever we are
physiologically animals and that's all
that mother nature cares about that's
what father Universe out there looks at
father universe doesn't care in mother
nature don't care
if we have a very sophisticated thought
process you know going on in our brains
okay
okay plasma today's plasma day okay we
why did I bring up plasma because the
other day I had a little a tet with my
son Adrian and he questioned whether my
reasoning was correct well uh after we
adjourn I beat him up gave him a black
eye you know
and now he understands okay he
understands plasma is
not a thing and that's what we're going
to say in fact one of the files just now
said hey Bill you don't understand what
plasma is
now uh plasmus and that in is okay and
let's go through it well what are we
talking about what is plasma well here's
a little picture of plasma to put it in
the right perspective so we have a good
starting point okay
uh not the one on the top okay that's uh
blood plasma okay now we're talking
about the guy on the bottom which uh
looks like a bunch of little balls
that's what it looks like to me what
does it look like to you okay it's got
all these arrows the arrows are
important okay because uh what they're
trying to the idea they're trying to
give you with that is that something is
in motion
so it's like like synthesizing Motion in
a photograph
okay and uh that's kind of weird we can
synthesize uh photographs like you know
frames in a movie but you can't do it
the other way around you can't have
um
uh what is it uh the Mona Lisa
smile in a photograph
okay because smile requires at least two
frames in a movie because a smile is a
verb
smile is not you know a photograph
before you can understand smile you have
to understand what seriousness is and
from Scenario seriously seriousness you
move to smile okay otherwise smile uh is
a verb okay no such thing as Smile as a
static image and this is where the
problem is okay so where do we start
well we start here uh how many states of
matter are there well there are only
three three states of matter they're
known as solid liquid and gas these are
the states of matter okay here you have
them okay examples okay here you have a
solid uh in the middle you have a liquid
and on the right you have what appears
to be a gas okay now if you look at
those uh do you see any motion
you know I mean is anything moving in
there in that picture
well I don't think so see you don't need
to have liquid move in order to call it
liquid like if you spill uh I don't know
milk on the floor okay
um
well you know you spill it on the floor
you say hey there's a liquid let's
assume you did not know what it was or
maybe it could be some clear liquid of
some kind maybe maybe it's water maybe
it's some kind of chemical uh liquid and
it's just on the floor and you say uh
what's that liquid
now the liquid is not rolling it's not
moving it's just there like a like a
chair would be there right it's not
moving you don't need to have Motion in
embodied in the word liquid okay now
liquid can also be thought of as
something that's flowing okay like you
could say a river is liquid right
because it flows but liquid the word
itself has a state of matter does not
have to be moving any more than a solid
has to be moving and the same with gas
you know if uh if I'd release some gas
in outer space okay and God freezes the
universe at that moment in time he does
a cross-section of time
I can still have gas you know that's a
picture guest does not have to be moving
in order for it to be gas and within the
word gas there should not be
um any motion it doesn't embody motion
um
but these people have created uh what
they call
the fourth state of matter
the fourth state
they say plasma is the fourth state
and I looked it up just to make sure
because I always thought Georgia was the
fourth state and I I verify that yeah
Georgia is the fourth state in fact uh
you know it came before plasma because
he came in 1788 and William Crooks came
up with Plasma in 1878 I had about 100
years later and I think it's they think
it's an island right off the coast of
Georgia Somewhere Out There plasma the
plasma Island
well anyways uh the point here is that
no plasma is not the fourth state okay
and you say well Bill everybody no
that's common knowledge plasma is the
fourth state okay let's find out
if that's true okay here we have it okay
that's plasma but you know I I see a
problem because it's a state of matter
but it doesn't be much of a state it
looks like it's moving looks like it's
moving all around something's happening
in in inside in front of my eyes I don't
know about yours but I see everything
moving now maybe I have to see a
ophthalmologist but uh as far as I can
tell you know everything is moving in
that picture
okay so the first question we have is
can you distinguish between these two
here here we'll put them side by side do
you see a difference between the three
states of matter on the left and the
fourth alleged state of matter on the
right
is there a difference between those
if you don't see a difference maybe you
should see an ophthalmologist okay you
got a problem with your eyes okay
and so um so what is the problem well
the problem is this word called state
okay
and uh here we see again uh the
differences between them the ones on the
top are photographs you can take a
snapshot of liquid you can take a
snapshot of gas
looks like a cloud of some kind let's
assume it's I don't know uh let's assume
it's
um
not phosphine because that's uh I don't
know some some gas that you released out
there you take a snapshot of it okay if
it's color coded and you can take a
snapshot and say that's gas
it's not liquid it's not a solid that's
gas
okay you don't know what gas it is it
doesn't matter the point is you can take
a snapshot of gas and call it gas
because the word gas under those in that
context does not require motion it does
not embody motion okay so gas liquid
picture I can point to them because I
can take a snapshot of them in the case
of uh
plasma I cannot if I take a snapshot you
know I got a problem because uh what I
have in front of me is not plasma I have
a bunch of little balls right uh with
tinier balls called electrons you know
next to them so I have big balls and
little balls that's all I have in front
of me okay and that's not plasma and
that's not gas I don't know what it is
it's just a bunch of balls okay if you
want the word plasma the word plasma
does embody motion you can't live
without Motion in the word plasma and
again it comes down to this word state
okay so we look up the word State and it
says a particular condition that someone
or something is in
at a specific time
at a specific time we're talking about a
cross-section of time we're talking
about God
slicing the universe stopping at the
universe at some point and saying okay
the universe stopped nothing moves in
the universe except me oh God you know
stops the whole universe whatever's
there is stopped nothing moves okay and
that's what a state is see solid is a
state
get liquid is a stain and gas is a state
plasma is not a state because it's not
at a specific time it needs an interval
of time it needs at least two frames in
a universal movie to conceptualize
plasma and uh state is a static concept
okay state is conceptually a
cross-section of time in the Universal
movie there is no motion embodied in a
state
okay so you cannot say that plasma is
the fourth state of matter because state
is a static concept plasma is not it
does not qualify under the word State
okay motion it requires two or more
locations of an object and the best way
to memorize
what a state is it's static
State ick okay that's what it is
state is a static concept okay so please
remember that and here uh let me show
you here uh parallel to that okay here
are the three states of matter plus uh
plasma
and where was the problem well the
problem is that if you look up the word
solid it says having three dimensions
length with breath and thickness which
are all three wrong thickness is not a
dimension and breath is not a dimension
either it's length width and height
breath is a vector it's not a it's not a
dimension or a coordinate says having
three dimensions as a geometrical body
or figure having relative uh firmness
coherence of particles or Persistence of
form as matter that is not liquid or
gaseous in other words when they talk
about solid they don't talk about motion
but when you talk about the other three
people Define them as having motion
liquid they talk about move gas they
talk about mobility and plasma you talk
about ionized
okay so this is where the confusion
starts but again we have to look at the
context in which we're using these words
if we're going to talk about the state
of matter there's only three solid
liquid and gas because for the words
these words they don't embody emotion
there's nothing embodying Motion in the
word solid liquid and gas under the
context where you say it's a state of
matter now uh do liquids move yeah
liquids move gases move if you heat
solids they will move to and turn into
liquid uh gas and maybe sublimation who
knows what else that's not the point the
point is the word solid the word liquid
the word gas under the context of a
state of matter they embody no motion
you cannot say the same thing about
plasma okay so this is this is where the
problem is
state is a static concept stands for
State ick static okay so uh you cannot
see the plasma is a static uh state of
matter okay so that's where the problem
is
okay here uh we have the word ionization
and ionization what is it a process
you know what a process is it's a verb
process means you're going to require at
least two frames of the universal movie
and there you see an example ionization
the movie okay we have an atom some kind
of atom there this is the uh planetary
model Boris planetary model it's going
to lose an electron that one up there
okay and in order to understand
ionization you need at least two frames
of the movie you need to remove in this
case this example you really need you
need to remove an electron from
the Adam and so removing is a verb
okay if plasma is the removal
then we have a problem plasma as being a
state of matter because uh plasma is
something in motion so it cannot be a
state call it whatever you want but it's
not a state okay ionization is what a
process by which an atom or a molecule
what gains or loses gains or loses verbs
right electrons during chemical what
changes
there's got to be a change what a change
a synonym of the word motion okay so uh
there you have it in a nutshell
plasma is not a state of matter because
state is a static concept
ionization is not an aesthetic concept
plasma is ionized gas therefore plasma
is not a state or anything in it's not a
static concept plasma is something in
motion you cannot synthesize it in a
single frame of the universal movie
understood
okay let's go with some of the questions
people made in some of the
Commons people made since last time okay
well says a field would be the collapse
of the big bangs waveform
he's gonna collapse a wave uh you know I
don't think these people realize about
that wave there is a bunch of vectors
that's all it is what's a vector
magnitude and Direction so how do you
collapse uh magnitude and Direction and
what and you know collapse it into what
into uh an equation or what are you
going to get out of a collapsed numbers
with Direction values with Direction
magnitude of directions
going from a particle to a wave
how do you turn a particle Assuming he's
talking about a ball I guess right I
mean what is a particle and to a bunch
of vectors well I don't know I want to
see you do that in a lab show me how you
can turn the particle you know turn turn
this ball right turn this ball into a
bunch of vectors
into a concept
I want to see you do that okay so I
don't know what he's talking about I can
only assume it's the cosmic microwave
background background radiation that
permeates the entire universe Okay the
third world's a uh the the third world
is a hallucinations supposedly mostly it
leads to holographic universe theory
these people just talk about nonsense so
much poppy cup comes out of their mouths
they don't even know what they're saying
they just memorize these cliches out
there they don't even want they don't
even know what they're talking about
it's just unbelievable uh how people get
brainwashed with this language they just
memorize it like poetry and recite it
that's it they don't even know what
they're saying
okay another fellow says let's see here
he says uh we observe Fields interacting
with matter
how do you have a field interacting with
matter
so we have to look up the word field
what is field field a physical quantity
that has a value for each point in space
and time so there you have a whole bunch
of numbers values you can put a unit
after them if you want I don't care the
point is we're talking about values
we're talking about numbers quantities
magnitudes Etc amounts
and then the way they Illustrated us
were these lines that have arrows I
don't know if there was engineeros what
kind of arrows those are but that ain't
an object as far as I'm concerned
I mean unless you can you know
convince us that you know we're staring
out of things
anyways uh so you cannot observe fields
to begin with but then how do you get
them to interact with matter when field
is a bunch of numbers in a bunch of
arrows I guess no way you know but those
arrows are not engine arrows again
they're not solid arrows again they
represent numbers values uh amounts
that's all those arrows represent so
yeah I I don't know uh these people
have to really get their act together in
trying to understand what they're saying
and I don't think they do okay here's
another fellow talking about field he
says those numbers shown here as
vibrating in the field are actually
vibrating by changing values not by
shaking
uh-huh that's an uh interesting point
um but the answer is no
okay the answer is no because see
in mathematics
they have that changes in values right
because that's what a field is a value
right at each point in space and what
this file is saying is that
those values change they increase and
decrease you know constantly and so it's
not a vibration like a physical
vibration it's just an increase in
decrease of a number so what he's saying
is that without any vibrating numbers
what what's actually happening is the
numbers uh going from five to six and
then back to five for example right so
it goes five six five six five six five
six that's not a vibration it's just
that the number locally is changing the
value is changing locally but see the
the issue is that um you can't do that
in physics okay you can't
extrapolate that to physics in physics
we need to have an object moving if
you're going to talk about use the word
vibration which is the word they use
they use the word excitation more more
commonly right so if a field an excited
field uh which is the term they use uh
what is that it means that something is
vibrating something is you know being
excited you know like when I get excited
right it's moving you can't say that
that's just a change in numbers a change
in values in in math you can right you
can say it's just a change in values and
you can use the word vibrating whatever
you want excitation no problem that's
over there but if you're going to bring
it into physics and you're going to use
the word excitation or vibration you're
talking about something else you're
talking about physical motion
again okay so we have to determine
whether a field belongs to mathematics
or if it belongs to physics if it
belongs to physics and they're going to
say it's by it's a vibrating field it's
an excited field
they have a problem okay because that
now they have to make the field visible
for us for our eyes we need to know what
physical object they're referring to
okay so let's get that straight there
okay another fellow says
geometry math isn't a part of science
correct geometry math is a tool used in
engineering
correct okay and Engineering what does
that was the branch of Technology
concerned with the design building and
use of engines machines and structures
uh what is science explanations
rational explanation so obviously
engineering has nothing to do with
science science has nothing to do with
engineering science we explained we have
to
explain rationally and in engineering
there in the business of Designing and
developing products things and that
doesn't concern science at all so yeah
geometry and math have nothing to do
with science okay it's the
mathematicians who forcefully
um
put math into physics and physics
so-called physics mathematical physics
into science neither mathematical
so-called physics neither math belong in
science okay they're not a branch of
science either one in fact mathematical
physics belongs more strictly you would
say in religion okay because they have
all these irrational explanations and I
don't even think that the religious folk
would accept them in as at least the
traditional but
what we consider traditional religions
now is it a religion yeah it is in a way
because uh mathematical physics is 150
belief the explanations they give are
all irrational and people just believe
them that's all there is and this is not
a question belief we don't try to shove
anything down anybody's throat we just
say look uh here's the explanation and
that's where science stops what
continues is your belief and that does
not concern science
okay here's another follow he says
making up your own dictionary
uh no it's not that we make our uh
dictionary okay it's that uh what
happens here is that uh you know
everybody can make up their own
dictionary if they want and there's no
problem with that you can you can go
ahead and make up your your dictionary
the question is can you defend your
definitions
what we're trying to voice to rely on
voting people saying I like your
definition and we have majority about 50
percent plus one uh like that definition
so that's what's going to rule no
absolutely not are we going to say this
the way we always did it tradition no
are we going to say well um
uh you know this is what everybody
believes in this is what what's in the
dictionary you know Authority uh not uh
none of those serve uh to justify your
definitions what justifies your
definition is reasoning okay if there's
a definition that is wrong because it's
been used in a wrong way officially in
uh in science if it's in your rational
definition it has to be revised period
you know and you may say well that's
something all the other people out there
believe in well know science is not by
majority rule okay science has to do
with explanations explanations could be
a single person in the world who has
that explanation and mother nature might
smile at that person and not at all the
others that's the way it works knowing
and believing are the same absolutely
because knowing is defined as Justified
true what belief
that's why yeah knowing and uh believing
are exactly are synonyms one is just I
guess uh a greater certainty that the
person has about his beliefs and that's
all it is he says I know I don't just
believe
you know I know okay that means you just
have stronger belief and you call it
knowledge okay that's all it is okay and
here we have a fellow says if time is
two motions and memory what two motions
are involved in a light year
well we have the little C there are 300
000 kilometers per second which is the
speed of light okay under the Rope model
is just the uh propagation of the
torsion you can say okay we can sense
something here and send something over
there and we call that uh the velocity
of light right and we say yeah it's a
300 000 kilometers per second that's one
motion then the other motions the orbit
of the Earth around the uh sun which is
one year so we have a light year speed
of light in one year
so those are the two motions okay very
clear very straightforward
okay
[Music]
um
here we have another fella and he says
are objects made of mass
uh no because mass is a concept
so objects are not made of Concepts and
why do emotions affect water
well the best I can give you is that you
know when you have high emotions
sometimes you cry sometimes you're even
laughing you laugh so hard that you cry
and so you have you know water dripping
down your eye uh that's the only context
that I can imagine where
uh emotions affect water
okay here we have Phil he says we
exclude C and touch in physics okay
since we can't see and touch uh the
mediator of magnetism and gravity Etc
don't we yeah correct yeah these senses
still play a role in other fields like
biology and the humanities well I'm not
sure what he's referring to but he gives
us an example if you think here why does
noticeable interaction with objects and
Concepts in these fields not play a role
when it comes to explaining the
mechanism behind phenomena
we have an idea of how eukaryote uh a
prokaryote work uh we know what the
citric acid cycle we know about the
citric acid cycle we know about these
processes due to experiment and
observation we didn't start with an
explanation only with an ocean
well the issue is the following okay and
uh I guess there's several issues that
he raises here but the main one I think
is no experiments have nothing to do
with science and neither do study you
can run whatever experiment you want in
your dark basement there's no problem
there nobody cares about that when you
come to the conference you need to
explain what you learned because if
science is just or biology or any of
those sciences that he mentioned which
are just subsets of science
if if science is just studying it's just
doing experiments in in your lab
um well then everybody's a scientist you
know uh even uh children would be
scientists uh you have someone in
kindergarten and he's studying you know
he's trying to learn something not
whether he did learn or not that's a
separate issue you know I don't know if
he learned he's going to show us what he
learned that when he takes the test or
something when he performs whatever he
learned you know he regurgitates what he
what he learned or he can explain
something but until he can do that the
fact that he uh just studied
or did an experiment you know I go to
the kitchen and you know put salt with
pepper hey I did an experiment did I
learn something other than sneezing that
produces sneezing uh no uh you know I
mean every anybody can do an experiment
here here I always do experiments here
look here's here's the most famous Bill
Gates experiment okay you let go of the
uh pencil right
and it falls to the floor right or to
the table right there it is I just let
it go so I did an experiment am I a
scientist because I did an experiment
or uh would the scientists be the fellow
who can explain why that fell downwards
instead of upwards right right I think
that's that's the issue
okay so no running experiments does not
make you a scientist studying does not
make you a scientist you want to be a
scientist you have to explain then then
you can show us
uh what you learned that that
something's working you know uh up on
the attic one and the other one you show
us there that you really are like that
first guy said earlier uh that uh we are
not animals right because otherwise if
if you just study and did experiments
can't explain anything
you certainly are closer to all other
animals in the Wild Kingdom
okay so here's ether ropes okay uh
that's what we say are uh
the famous
waves are uh really the ropes so we
always try to point that out to people
okay for those of you who want to
understand and why do I put that in
there because a fellow asked the
following he says uh do I understand
correctly that the ropes don't pull and
that the force of attraction is seen in
the number of atoms in an object
actually that's not quite true okay
we're saying that the attraction is a
function of how many ropes independent
rows uh I call them effective ropes
those are the ropes that are not on the
same axis so it's a quantity of ropes
that are not on the same axis okay and
there's an illustration right there at
the bottom it's very hard to explain
something when you have a a movie that
is giving you the explanation right
there in front of you I still don't
understand how falling happens when the
ropes don't pull
yes the ropes do not pull uh I always
want to clarify that because we always
think of gravity as a pull force and
yeah the two objects are being pulled
towards each other but the ropes are not
doing any kind of pulling each
individual rope is not doing a pulling
what happens between the two atoms as
far as the Rope is concerned it's a um
it's in a static concept known as
tension it's under tension what is
tension tension means no one wins the
tug of war okay tension is not a force
because it doesn't pull or push it no
one nothing moves during tension tension
you have to think more like you know a
dumbbell
uh two balls uh mediated or uh Bound by
a stick a rigid stick you can say it's
the whole thing is made out of a single
piece that's called tension that's more
or less the notion of tension neither
ball moves closer to the other ball uh
in other words there's no push or pull
it's a tie game no one wins the tug of
war so that's tension if if every atom
in the universe is simply under tension
with respect to every other atom then
what you have is that as one object made
out of atoms approaches another
object made out of atoms then the ropes
as they get closer you know fan out and
that's what I'm illustrating there at
the bottom I'm not sure how else I can
illustrate that for you to understand
the pull of gravity meaning between
objects not the ropes okay the ropes
don't pull there's tension it's only a
question how many ropes fan out because
the farther away they are they're all in
the same Axis or more or less it's like
a single coaxial but as they approach
they fan out that's all I can tell you
uh is the fan out depending out of the
ropes the force and the acceleration do
we have to get away from the term Force
when it comes to gravity uh you can use
the word Force when you talk about the
objects
not about what happens between two atoms
a single rope there is no Force there
the force only happens between the
objects made out of atoms so if you have
a table and a chair one's on the moon
and the other one's uh on the earth and
on the table or the chair comes towards
the Earth the closer it gets to the uh
to the other object the other piece of
furniture the more the ropes will fan
out and that's all I can tell you it's
just the Fanning out the ropes each
individually is only under tension okay
and that's the best way I can put it I
don't know if uh you'll just have to try
to visualize uh the Fanning out of the
ropes that is the mechanism of gravity
according to the site
with that I'll see you on Sunday uh
we'll see you there bye